zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
schluss mit den corona maßnahmen seit
heute gibt es in england so gut wie
keine corona beschränkungen mehr keine
masken keine impf nachweise mehr wenn
man in irgendein restaurant oder
irgendein in irgendeine diskothek möchte
nächste woche will auch dänemark seinen
freedom day feiern england und dänemark
waren mit die ersten europäischen länder
auf die die omikron welle zugerollt ist
es gibt immer noch täglich zehntausende
fälle aber trotzdem wagen sie dort jetzt
den exit
darüber sprechen wir mit ihnen und euch
wie immer die fragen in die kommentare
oder wenn ihr die app nutzt bitte an die
eingeblendete e-mail-adresse zdf heute -
live at
zdf.de und ich sehe hier im chat da
freut sich tarek partie schon über das
thumbnail
das gebe ich gerne weiter an die
kolleginnen die das gebaut haben und ich
sehe auch eine
nachricht von onkel decks der sagt lass
laufen wird schon schiefgehen das ist
die große frage kann man es auch laufen
lassen und es wird schon gut gehen und
die frage die sich hier in deutschland
vor allem viele stellen ist wann lassen
wir es laufen und warum machen wir es
jetzt noch nicht darüber sprechen wir
gleich auch mit einem virologen blicken
jetzt aber erstmal auf die lage in
england
in england fallen bei sinkender
incidents schon heute die masken und mit
ihnen die sogenannten plan b maßnahmen
dann gilt in den meisten räumen keine
masten pflicht mehr und auch impfen oder
test nachweisen müssen nicht mehr
kontrolliert werden das galt in england
ohnehin nur bei großveranstaltungen und
clubs
wir werden dem urteil des britischen
volkes vertrauen und niemanden mehr
kriminalisieren und der sich dafür
entscheidet keine maske zu tragen denn
nach enorm steigender sieben tage
incidents ist im vereinigten königreich
zuletzt wieder gesunken auf mittlerweile
unter 1000 in großbritannien sind rund
70 prozent der bevölkerung zweifach
geimpft in deutschland etwa drei prozent
mehr in beiden ländern ist rund die
hälfte der bevölkerung mittlerweile
gewusst hat im vergleich dazu
unterscheiden sich die zahlen der
bestätigten corona fälle seit beginn der
pandemie aber deutlich während es in
deutschland rund 92 millionen corona
fälle gibt hat großbritannien bei 67
millionen einwohnern rund 16,2 millionen
bestätigte fälle und in den vergangenen
zwei jahren auch deutlich mehr corona
tote stadt auf konkrete maßnahmen setzt
die regierung die aber in zukunft auf
empfehlungen und ratschläge wie
andreas stammen unser korrespondent in
london zugeschaltet hier gibt es einen
kommentar von leon star 811 über youtube
der sagt natürlich das ist richtig das
ist das leben und überschaubares risiko
gehört einfach dazu das sind auch unsere
bürgerrechte die uns schon viel zu lange
gestohlen wurden ist dass die
vorherrschende meinung auch in england
das ist zumindest die vorherrschende
meinung bei den regierenden
konservativen
die sich ja sozusagen dieses alte
liberale motto der eigenverantwortung
gern auf ihre fahnen schreiben man muss
aber bei allem ein bisschen dann das gas
rausnehmen denn die einschränkungen die
es hier gab dieser sogenannte plan b das
war wirklich minimal invasiv das muss
man mal sagen das war masken tragen in
belebten an belebten orten im
öffentlichen nahverkehr noch nicht mal
den restaurants das war eben ein
negativer schnelltests wenn man oder
eben geimpften status wenn man eben in
großveranstaltungen wollte also wirklich
massenveranstaltungen wie fußballspiele
premier league hier lief eigentlich
alles weiter das heißt das war er sehr
minimal invasiv und war sozusagen ein
minimum an einschränkungen das man geben
wollte aufgrund der zahlen die omikron
dann hervorbrachte und man hat eben drei
szenarien und es ist eben das beste
aller szenarien eingetreten dass trotz
unglaublich hohe infektionszahlen
250.000 tägliche fälle in der spitze
eben die krankenhäuser nicht von
schweren verläufen überflutet wurden und
das war eben jetzt hat man dann eben
gedacht okay man hat das gesehen das ist
milder und es bleibt das
gesundheitssystem stabil es kann das
aushalten und dann kann man die
einschränkung zurücknehmen weniger
glaube ich weil er groß die freiheit
getönt wird sondern weil es halt
wirtschaftlich dieses land extrem hart
getroffen hat als eine der härtesten im
oecd-vergleich also in den westlichen
industrienationen und das war ein
motivator zu sagen diese einschränkungen
sind eben schlecht fürs geschäft und das
kann man sich nicht und will man sich
nicht mehr länger leisten wir haben denn
die leute jetzt heute reagiert das ist
ja quasi schon der zweite freedom days
hat er schon mal einen gegeben ich
erinnere mich als in israel die masten
gefallen sind da war das netz voll von
fotos von lächelnden leuten man hat
wieder gesichter gesehen die masken
waren weg die haben das richtig gefeiert
wie war das heute in england und tragen
die leute vielleicht auch trotzdem jetzt
weiter maske auch wenn sie es nicht
müssen einfach weil sie es wollen oder
weil es ihnen geraten wird auch von
supermarkt betreibern zum beispiel
also wie gesagt diese dieser
einschränkung die heute fallen dass das
bewegt hier niemanden groß denn
diejenigen die maske weiter tragen
wollen die werden das weiter tun und das
ist hin ich hätte mal zwei drittel der
menschen die sagen ich bin mal lieber
vorsichtig es wird ja auch empfohlen
weiterhin eben in supermärkten oder bei
veranstaltungen wo man viele menschen um
sich hat manche supermärkte sagen auch
man soll es weiter machen das ist eben
nicht mehr gesetzlich vorgeschrieben
einzige ausnahme eben im londoner
öffentlichen personennahverkehr da sagt
der bürgermeister nein ist mir zu
riskant die masken pflicht gilt hier
weiter das problem ist aber und das war
auch beim letzten mal so denn die masken
pflicht in london galt eigentlich immer
im öffentlichen nahverkehr dass das
niemanden mehr durchsetzen kann weil die
polizei sagt es war business anymore das
interessiert uns jetzt nicht mehr weil
es nicht mehr gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist dann ist es sozusagen
eine freiwillige maßnahme die regierung
sagt macht das seid vorsichtig aber es
liegt eben in der eigenverantwortung und
das ist sozusagen der stand du hast das
gesundheitssystem angesprochen hier
fragt becketts auch über youtube ist
unser gesundheitssystem nicht viel
stabiler als in großbritannien kann man
nicht nach englands zweitem freedom day
mal was davon lernen also falls es gut
geht wie ist das mit dem
gesundheitssystem kannst du darauf
nochmal ein bisschen genauer eingehen
also das britische gesundheitssystem ist
unterteilt oder das englische die vier
großen energies nordirland wales
schottland england und das läufen
bisschen anders das ist in
steuerfinanziert aus mitteln der
regierung ist ein bisschen
unterfinanziert muss man sagen und das
drückt sich zum beispiel aus das ist
glaube ich nur ein sechstel der
intensivbetten pro 100000 gibt wie zum
beispiel in deutschland also hier kommt
man sehr viel schneller an seine grenzen
was hat geholfen bei dieser welle zum
einen eben es gab eben wesentlich
weniger schwere verläufe warum die hohe
impfquoten die es ähnlich in deutschland
aber wenn man sich die zahlen genau
anschaut und fällt einem auf über 60
also bei denen die am meisten gefährdet
sind in dieser pandemie ist die
impfquote in großbritannien 95 prozent
mehr als 95% doppelt kämpft und über 85
prozent sind auch gepustet und das hat
natürlich unglaublich geholfen um die
zahl der schweren verläufe niedrig zu
halten und die verstopfen in
anführungszeichen die krankenhäuser die
menschen die dort ewig lange liegt und
dann gibt es nicht genug intensivbetten
und dann kommt es schnell zum kollaps
und das haben wir hier vor einem jahr
gesehen da waren die krankenhäuser in
london nicht und da sind leute die einen
herzinfarkt gelitten haben es kam kein
krankenwagen es war kein platz mehr auf
den intensivstationen wir haben das
miterlebt und es war eine unangenehme
zeit und das war bei omikron einfach
nicht der fall omikron ist anders und
das war das große glück denn dieses
gesundheitssystem ist seit zwei jahren
völlig am limit und eine welle wie
letztes jahr alpha war dass das hätte
das gesundheitssystem nicht überstanden
nun ist natürlich auch eine große frage
die der infrastruktur auch das hat man
ja in deutschland befürchtet wenn hier
die omikron wand kommt dann könnte es zu
ausfällen bei der polizei kommen auch
bei der gesundheitsversorgung weil dann
einfach ganz viele leute zwar nicht
schwer krank sind aber eben zu hause und
nicht arbeiten können hier fragt ein
user wenn es jede woche neue
rekordzahlen gibt kann man nicht an
lockerungen denken wie hat das denn in
england funktioniert diese ausfälle muss
es ja dort auch gegeben haben oder muss
es jetzt immer noch geben oder wie wird
das land am laufen gehalten trotz dieser
incident
also die die kranken der krankenstands
meldungen die waren schon enorm denn man
hatte teilweise in den betrieben ein
viertel bis ein drittel der leute waren
einfach nicht da waren krank gemeldet
oder haben sie in quarantäne befunden
weil sie eben sehr eng einen kontakt
hatten mit erkrankten und das war
schwierig das war für ein zwei wochen
wirklich schwierig für viele betriebe
dinge am laufen zu halten man hat in den
supermärkten gemerkt da fehlten sachen
zum beispiel es immer schwierig im
moment aus grund auf vielen gründen aber
da war noch mal extra man hat es an
allen ecken und enden gemerkt ist wurden
zugverbindungen gestrichen es gab
einfach weniger angebot in vielen
bereichen aber man hat das relativ
schnell und gut überbrückt und dann
gegen die zahlen ja auch schnell wieder
runter und ich glaube das war eben der
große vorteil es war ein kurzer
intensiver schock aber den konnte man
irgendwie aushalten also wenn die zahlen
länger so bleiben wird es ganz schwierig
und man hat auch reagiert die quarantäne
wurde auf fünf tage verkürzt wenn man
sagt den leute müssen wieder zurück an
die arbeit die fehlen dort und man weiß
eigentlich statistisch dass ein drittel
der infizierten nach fünf tagen noch
ansteckend sind also das war sozusagen
in der not muss man eben harte maßnahmen
durchführen
eine frage noch andrea sie guckt nur
währenddessen ganz kurz in den jetta ist
eine heiße diskussion für und gegen das
impfen
entbrannt an der stelle gerne der
hinweis hier schauen wir in die anderen
nachbarländer die diskussion haben wir
auch schon oft geführt im stream dazu
findet ihr auch viel auf unseren kanälen
also vielleicht informiert ihr euch da
und verlagert die diskussion einfach
dorthin ein kompliment noch bevor ich
die letzte frage an die stelle von kruse
61 61 heute live macht das super ich
fühle mich qualitativ sehr gut
informiert ehrlich vielen dank vielen
herzlichen dank an dieser stelle fürs
kompliment und jetzt andreas die
politische frage wie sehr ist das denn
überhaupt politisch motiviert dass es
diesen freedom day 2.0 jetzt gibt mitten
in der grössten politischen krise die
boris johnson
herr boris johnson steht ja hier massiv
unter druck weil das einfach in den
letzten zwei jahren während lockdown
zwehren corona einschränkungen galten
neben mir hier intent downing street in
seinem amts und wohnsitz da wurde
kräftig gefeiert und er hat wohl kräftig
gelogen darüber dann hat immer gesagt
nein als das herauskam es wurde nicht
gefeiert wurden sie an alle regeln
gehalten und hat so scheibchenweise
zugeben müssen dass das wohl nicht der
fall war das ganze wird mittlerweile von
der polizei untersucht und boris johnson
fällt nicht über diesen skandal denn das
sind es geht um ordnungswidrigkeiten es
geht um bußgelder aber wenn er eben das
parlament belogen hat dann liegt es eben
in der daher in der partei in seiner
partei zu entscheiden ist er noch
tragbar als premierminister und das wird
eine ganz enge kiste wenn diese berichte
wenn die mal rauskommen was genau
schiefgelaufen ist und wenn der
bewertungen vor allen dingen von der
polizei vorgenommen werden und dann muss
er eben sich vielleicht einem
misstrauensvotum stellen und er sammelt
jetzt die truppen und alles was er jetzt
tut hat auch ein bisschen so den
anschein als ob er jedes argument jede
maßnahme bringt um seine eigene partei
zu besänftigen um so viele wie möglich
auf seine seite zu ziehen und viele
tories verstehen sich eben als liberal
haben mit diesen einschränkungen coroner
beschränkungen erhebliche mühe gehabt
sich immer schwer getan damit und damit
gibt also ein kleines bisschen zucker
und das kostet ihn auch nicht viel weil
die gesagt diese einschränkung man
minimal und haben sozusagen jetzt hier
keine freudenstürme ausgelöst in der
bevölkerung aber politisch kann es ihm
helfen eben einen oder anderen eine
gruppe von abgeordneten wieder auf seine
seite zu ziehen und am ende könnte das
vielleicht den ausschlag geben über ich
bleibe im amt oder ich verabschiede mich
apropos ich verabschiede mich andreas
stamm ich verabschiede dich an dieser
stelle vielen dank dass du mit dem
streamen dabei war es danke für diese
eindrücke aus england und wir machen
weiter mit einem der sich auskennt mit
viren professor ulrich dittmar chef
virologie der uniklinik essen schön dass
sie uns zugeschaltet sind heute im
stream herr professor dittmer
wäre das der richtige zeitpunkt auch in
deutschland zu sagen wir beenden die
korona maßnahmen
ja guten abend nein es ist bei uns nicht
der richtige zeitpunkt wir haben ja ein
ganz anderen stand in der mikrowelle als
england oder dänemark zum beispiel wir
sind nämlich noch vor dem absoluten
höhepunkt der angekommen zahlen england
ist schon deutlich dahinter und insofern
ist das bei uns nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt um alles zu lockern wir
blicken gleich auch noch nach dänemark
da ist die situation ja so dass die
zahlen weiter steigen und trotzdem
gelockert wird aber das können wir uns
gleich im detail noch mal angucken ein
user marcel es fragt über youtube die
nachbarländer heben alle maßnahmen auf
und wir diskutieren über die impfpflicht
wie passt das zusammen
können sie nochmal einen zusammenhang
herstellen zwischen der zahl der
geimpften und möglichen
lockerungsschritte
ja wir haben das in den bericht schon
gehört das große problem dass wir in
deutschland haben ist dass viele über 60
jährige nicht viel mehr als dass in
england oder dänemark der fall ist das
sind in deutschland nach ungefähr drei
millionen menschen und wir wissen immer
noch nicht genau wie stark letztendlich
erkrankungen sind bei einer nikon
infektion von älteren hier kann eine
ganz andere situationen auftreten als
das in england der fall ist oder gewesen
ist und insofern ist mir sehr wichtig
vor allen dingen dass diese älteren
menschen an sich noch impfen allerdings
kommt es für diese welle die jetzt auf
uns zukommt eigentlich sowieso zu spät
muss man sagen sie haben einblicke auch
in den krankenhausalltag in essen können
sie uns den schildern
ja in der letzten woche ist es hier
wirklich extrem angespannt geworden es
ist so dass wir auf den
intensivstationen zum glück ein sehr
entspanntes bild haben dass es völlig
anders als das in der del-tabelle der
fall war hier haben wir relativ wenig
patienten an eine wirklich kontrollierte
lage wir haben aber sehr sehr viel
personal ausfälle im gesamten
krankenhaus und das macht die arbeit auf
allen anderen stationen sehr schwierig
und wir haben
inzwischen und das war auch in england
so muss man sagen
einen sehr großen zustrom von patienten
die wir eigentlich nur ein zwei tage auf
der normalstation aufnehmen also kurve
19 patienten die brauchen aber ein zwei
tage medizinische versorgung und
betreuung weil es ihnen doch relativ
schlecht geht allerdings nicht so dass
sie jemals auf die intensivstation
müssten und diese dann jetzt noch viele
menschen verstopfen inzwischen bei uns
die notaufnahme wir können den patienten
von daraus nicht mehr ab verlegen und
wir haben auch große platzprobleme auf
den normalen stationen und genau dieses
phänomen hat es in england auch gegeben
in den usa übrigens auch und zwar so
schlimm dass andere krankheiten nicht
mehr versorgt werden konnten aber man
ist dann am autounfall gestorben weil
man keine möglichkeit hatte ins
krankenhaus zu kommen was ist ihre
perspektive für die nächsten wochen wenn
die zahlen weiter so steigen und das
werden sie ja tun
ja es ist so dass wir gesagt das hat
jetzt in der letzten woche begonnen das
wird sicherlich in den nächsten zwei
wochen noch schlimmer werden bei uns
auch wir brauchen pragmatische
ansätze dass wir menschen die in der
quarantäne sind oder infiziert sind und
deswegen isoliert sind möglichst schnell
in die bereiche zurückkriegen weil sonst
sind wir nicht mehr funktionsfähig als
krankenhaus
und in den nächsten zwei wochen
zumindestens erwartet dass die situation
sich noch deutlich verschärft erst dann
werden wir die spitze der amicom bälle
oder wand in deutschland erreicht haben
dann blicken wir jetzt nach dänemark
denn auch wenn wie gerade angesprochen
die zahlen dort weiter steigen sagt
heute die dänische ministerpräsidentin
auf wiedersehen zu einschränkungen und
hallo zu dem leben das wir vor corona
kannten so sagt es mitte fredriksen und
die lage in dänemark fast laura rosinus
für uns zusammen
erst im februar gibt es in dänemark an
den meisten orten keine masken pflicht
mehr trotz rekord incidents mit
mittlerweile über 5000 und seit wochen
zahlen auf hohem niveau auch im
nachweise werden ab nächster woche nicht
mehr kontrolliert und klubsuche und
großveranstaltungen sind dann wieder
normal möglich
wir sagen auf wiedersehen zu
einschränkungen und hallo zu dem leben
das wir vor corinna kannten damit folgt
die politik in der martin empfehlungen
der zuständigen kommission und lässt
ihre corona maßnahmen auslaufen möglich
gemacht hat das die hohe
impfbereitschaft und nur selten
auftretende schwere krankheitsverläufe
durch unicom denn über 80 prozent der
dänen sind mittlerweile doppelt geimpft
und mehr als 60 prozent schon gepostet
und auf den dänischen intensivstationen
werden zurzeit gerade einmal 44 menschen
behandelt
tja und jetzt sind wir bei herrmann
bernd in kiel der dort unser
skandinavien studio leitet hermann m wie
reagieren die dänen auf diese
politischen ankündigungen
ja es kann die nachricht gelassen
eigentlich genauso wie eben geschildert
in london ja die entscheidung ist da
mitte frederiksen die
ministerpräsidentin herzlich gestern
abend verkündet und man nimmt es halt
locker gelassen hin der eigentliche tag
ist ja auch erst der erste februar aber
die dänen hatten ja auch schon mal am 10
september das vergnügen dass die
epidemische lage
endet und wenige wochen später im
oktober waren dann die restriktiven
maßnahmen wieder da weil die zahlen
extrem gestiegen sind und das kam mir
eben auch schon raus man ist so ein
bisschen zurückhaltend das ist so die
mentalitätsfrage
man hat gesehen wie schnell sich die
lage ändern kann und vielleicht noch ein
aspekt dazu zur mentalität man nimmt
auch maßnahmen wie die bitte lasst euch
impfen das nimmt man in dänemark alt an
wir sind ja nicht weit weg von der
dänischen grenze nur 70 kilometer sitzer
flensburg von kiel und so die mentalität
ist butter kommt also das erklärt
vielleicht auch diese extrem hohe
impfrate 80 prozent ab den zwölfjährigen
und ähnlich wie in england auch bei den
über 50-jährigen 90 prozent das sind
schon enorm gute zahlen und vielleicht
noch ein aspekt die dänen haben auch
schon als die sie waren ja auch die
pioniere beim impfen als sie waren die
ersten die wirklich diese impfmaßnahmen
vorangetrieben haben schon letztes jahr
im mai lag die quote bei 75 prozent
also vielleicht sollten die die im chat
unterwegs sind echt mal zu hören weil
also die lockerung in dänemark gibt es
halt weil dort so viele leute geimpft
sind hermann das kann man ganz eindeutig
sagen das ist das ist ganz klar so dass
sagt sagen auch alle beteiligten das
sagt die regierung dass der
gesundheitsminister die
ministerpräsidentin aber auch die
zuständige kommission die die regierung
berät und dann ist natürlich bis eben
aus sondern auch anklang wir haben genau
dieselbe situation im vergleich zu 1
jahr also vor einem jahr war die lage
doch schwieriger auch bei der
hospitalisierung und jetzt hat man
gemerkt dass ich eben im beitrag diese
zahl
40 menschen in intensivbehandlung
das ist schon sehr stabil ja dass es in
der tat mehr als stabil vor allem bei
einer inzidenz von über 5.000 es ist ja
schon bemerkenswert und das ist
natürlich auch genau der grund warum man
hier noch angst hat zu lockern weil man
angst hat dass das gesundheitssystem
überfordert wird wie gehen denn die
dänen damit um weil auch da ist eher die
frage was mache ich denn wenn alle
kinder zu hause betreut werden müssen
weil die schulen zu sind weiß quarantäne
fälle gibt falls infektionsfälle gibt
wir haben denn die dänen das
infrastruktur problem gelöst
ja eigentlich haben wir denen das
infrastrukturprobleme schon vor
jahrzehnten gelöst nämlich sie haben
eine hervorragende medizinische
versorgung übrigens auch es gibt ja
viele ländlich geprägte regionen wie
genau die hinter der grenze südjütland
oder die region rund um kopenhagen
seeland also es gibt auch in den
mittleren städten mit 30 40 000 roland
hervorragend ausgestattete krankenhäuser
aber ein kernproblem
ist nach wie vor auch der personalmangel
man will halt vieles auf einmal
erreichen war will die versorgung in
krankenhäusern auf dem top level halten
man will dort die versorgung auf einem
sehr hohen level halten und man will
natürlich auch die impfkampagne am
laufen halten und extrem viele tests
gibt's also dafür braucht man personal
wir hatten jetzt neulich mal die
gelegenheit über die grenze zu gucken da
gibt es wirklich aktionen bei denen man
fachfremde auch studenten an lernt wie
sie impfen und das ist auch so ein
typisches technisches team soll ich
machen die machen einfach wäre
vielleicht machen ganz gute eine ganz
gute gelegenheit gewesen auch schon in
den letzten zwei jahren mal nach
dänemark zu gucken ein land in das viele
geguckt haben ist schweden vielleicht
können einen kleinen ausflug noch dahin
machen denn da sehen wir die haben ja
auch ein wenig maßnahmen gehabt die
ganze pandemie über hindurch aber jetzt
gibt es auch in schweden was wenig
maßnahmen kannte
vergleichsweise strenge maßnahmen wie
wie gehen denn die schweden mit dieser
mikrowelle um die gilt grundsätzlich
genau das ist ja ein skandinavisches
ding also auch phänomen also wenn man
von staatlicher seite das angeordnet
wird gibt es jetzt auf den ersten blick
nicht so schrecklich viele proteste
einen unterschied zwischen dänemark und
schweden gibt es aber dort gibt es jetzt
doch so ein bisschen aufbegehren weil
die regierung halt auch kontrollen in
sachen impfnachweis auch im öffentlichen
raum haben will und da gab es schon ein
paar proteste aber generell gilt
das kann auch eben in london heraus
diese eigenverantwortung man sagt jetzt
sollte es machen und viele folgen dem
auch und das ist vielleicht so ein
unterschied sagte ich aber zu südlich
der elbe also das würde in vielen teilen
mitteleuropas zeit nicht so stattfinden
sagt herrmann bernd aus kiel vielen dank
für die einblicke in das skandinavische
gesundheitssystem und die skandinavische
seele vielen dank nach kiel und wir
hören noch mal rein was jens lundgren
sagt das ist ein dänischer professor für
infektionskrankheiten und er hat auch
noch mal erklärt inwiefern diese dieses
loslösen von den maßnahmen gut und
sinnvoll sein kann
betont das heißt zum ersten mal in der
pandemie haben wir es einer virus
variante erlaubt sich auf natürliche
weise in der bevölkerung zu entwickeln
alle bisherigen wellen haben ihren
höhepunkt während der einschränkungen
erreicht diese wellen wurden gestoppt
weil die maßnahmen eingeführt worden
sind aber im fall von omikron hatte die
variante die möglichkeit sich zu
verbreiten ohne das irgendwie versucht
wurde sie zu stoppen
tja und damit sind wir wieder bei
professor steht man dem chef geologen
der uniklinik essen wenn sie den
kollegen da gerade hören und wenn wir
uns auch bewusst machen dass wir heute
exakt zwei jahre nach dem ersten
bestätigten fall in deutschland sind und
wir erleben dass diese welle tatsächlich
mehr oder minder ungebremst durch uns
durch rauscht wie bewerten sie das
ja ich glaube nicht dass sie ungebremst
durch uns durchaus und deutschland
tatsächlich
ist die steigerungsrate wie wir gesehen
haben geringer als in anderen ländern
man arbeite stellen fest dass angekommen
so infektiös ist dass man sehr sehr
viele infektionen auch mit maßnahmen
eben nicht verhindern kann
und es ist natürlich ein großes glück
letztendlich dass dieses virus längst
nicht so deutlich aus wie das sehr sehr
tödliche delta blues das gefährlichste
videos in dieser pandemie was wir bisher
hatten
warum ist es besser geimpft zu sein als
sich zu infizieren
jammern wir genau das sehen was auch in
dem beitrag angeklungen ist was wir in
dänemark eben sehen wenn man geimpft ist
kann man sich mit omikron auf infizieren
das ist denke ich tatsache dass wissen
jetzt alle warm aber man landet nicht
auf der intensivstation das risiko ist
gleich null auf der intensivstation zu
landen wenn man vollständig kämpft ist
und auch das risiko auf der
normalstation in einem krankenhaus zu
landen weil man ein oder zwei tage
sauerstoff braucht und sich wirklich
richtig krank fühlt auch das risiko ist
deutlich reduziert
wenn man geimpft ist und insofern
schützt die impfung weiter hervorragend
gegen jegliche erkrankung die der schutz
vor infektionen bei omi cordes dagegen
eingeschränkt nun haben wir gelernt in
diesen zwei jahren das hier
ungehinderter sich dieses virus
ausbreiten kann desto bequemer ist es
für das virus zu mutieren jetzt erleben
wir dass es sehr sehr viele menschen
infiziert können sie nochmal erklären
warum das nicht dazu beiträgt dass es
mutiert sondern eher das gegenteil zur
folge hat
naja es trägt dazu bei dass es mutiert
das sehen wir auch gerade wieder es
entstehen neue varianten von anne krank
ich denke nicht dass eine variante
entsteht wieder sehr viel schlimmere
krankheit verursacht weil das ist
eigentlich gegen das prinzip der
evolution
bei delta war es so es wurde sehr viel
tieferes gewebe infiziert die lunge
nervengewebe fettgewebe das ist mein
mikro nicht der fall deswegen kann nikon
sich besser vom oberen nasen rachen
tagaus verbreiten und hat damit einen
vorteil in der verbreitung und das wird
sozusagen nicht wieder evolutionär
zurückgedreht werden trotzdem wird
umgekommen sich verändern weiter
genetisch das sehen wir jetzt schon
nun sagt hier mister mini me 5 7 6 aber
natürlich muss man es so machen wie
england und dänemark nur die
apokalyptiker wie lauterbach sind
dagegen dass jetzt natürlich ziemlich
zugespitzt unter lauter aber würde sich
wahrscheinlich nicht als apokalyptiker
bezeichnen aber fest steht dass man ja
irgendwann auch in deutschland ein exit
irgendwie finden muss auch aus den
maßnahmen ab wann wäre denn der punkt
erreicht an dem man es verantworten kann
zu lockern aus ihrer sicht
ja natürlich wir brauchen wir auch in
deutschland ein access keiner möchte in
dieser der schleife bleiben und wenn wir
ein virus jetzt haben die angekommen was
nicht mehr so schwere krankheitssymptome
verursacht brauchen wir eine exit
strategie es ist gut dass dänemark und
england in der welle vor und sind und
dass wir uns angucken können was dort in
den ländern passiert wenn wir hinter dem
peak der mikrowelle sind müssen wir
unbedingt über exit strategien sprechen
aber im moment sehen wir folgendes und
das ist keine apokalypse die
notaufnahmen in den krankenhäusern sind
voll mit zwar nicht so schwer erkranken
aber immerhin kommt 19 erkranken und
menschen den schlaganfall haben oder ein
anderes problem können nicht mehr da
reinkommen sie kriegen kein bett mehr
das ist eine dramatische situation die
wir genauso in den usa zum beispiel
gesehen haben und deswegen müssen wir
noch ein zwei wochen so gut wie möglich
jede infektion zu verhindern
aber weil wir ansonsten andere
medizinische probleme in deutschland
nicht mehr richtig behandeln kann
das schreibt auch der user alexander
rath was hier sehr viele vergessen nicht
nur corona patienten müssen ins
krankenhaus jeder vermeidbare corona
patient im krankenhaus nimmt einem
normalen kranken einen platz weg würden
sie das so unterschreiben
ja das unterschreibe ich sofort sagen
tatsächlich so dass nur sehr wenige
menschen wahrscheinlich in dieser welle
an kurt 19 sterben werden weil direkt an
dieser infektion aber wir werden die
sogenannten kollateralschäden sehen wie
man eben in den usa und auch in england
gesehen haben menschen werden an anderen
erkrankungen sterben weil das
gesundheitssystem durch die vielen
kranken selber im gesundheitssystem
durch den personalausfall und die
verstopfung der eingangs wege ins
krankenhaus nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert und das haben wir in den
anderen ausgesehen sagte der chefgeologe
der uniklinik essen professor ulf
dittmer vielen dank dass sie heute abend
im stream dabei waren und auch ihnen und
euch wo auch immer ihr seid vielen dank
fürs mitmachen mit kommentieren und
einen schönen abend und bis zum nächsten
mal